Dr. Dan anxiously paced his cell.
It was the only way he’d been able to occupy
himself for the past six months, save for
poring through files and, when he was lucky,
being able to oversee another failed termination
attempt.
He only stopped pacing when, for a brief and
horrible moment, he realized that monster
was probably doing the exact same thing in
its big, metal cube at this very moment.
That horrible creature that he’d thrown
away his life for a futile shot at killing.
Perhaps the whole thing had been a fool’s
errand.
After all, he was formerly a researcher under
the employ of the SCP Foundation.
Secure, Contain, Protect.
They had truly sadistic beasts like SCP-106,
the nightmarish Old Man, and SCP-352, Baba
Yaga, in containment cells, and there were
no plans to terminate either of them.
They weren’t the Global Occult Coalition,
for 343’s sake.
Why did Dr. Dan even want to terminate SCP-096
in the first place?
He’d tried to explain it to them again and
again, but his pleas had fallen on deaf ears.
In his mind, the impetus for destroying the
Shy Guy was terrifyingly clear.
It was a monster that killed anyone or anything
that looked at its face, even a photograph
of it, even a tiny collection of pixels.
When its rage state was induced, it seemed
that nothing would stop it.
It would have an intuitive psychic link to
its victim, charge at them at breakneck speed,
and only find its zen again once all of them
were dead.
And if a picture of SCP-096 was leaked onto
the Internet, it would cause a chain reaction
that triggered an XK-Class End of the World
Scenario.
There were plenty of creatures and entities
that the Foundation knew about that could
theoretically bring about the apocalypse,
but to him, 096 was the most realistic.
It preyed upon the inherent curiosity and
thirst for knowledge seeded in every human
heart.
The same drive to simply Know that led to
the creation of the SCP Foundation would be
humanity’s doom in the face of an SCP-096
outbreak, and if such a thing happened, the
Foundation would need to break the Masquerade
of secrecy to have any hope of saving humanity.
In his many feverish nightmares, Dr. Dan had
seen it all so clearly.
The first photographs of SCP-096’s face
would be leaked online.
Perhaps a few hundred people across the globe
would look, in disparate enough locations
that it would be almost impossible for the
Foundation to detect and save all of them
as SCP-096 went on its bloody rampage.
Of course, as the image proliferated, as images
on the internet do, the purview of 096’s
violence would only grow.
People across the nation would start to take
notice.
And soon after that, across the world.
“Mysterious creature causing mass casualties”
would be the headline on every news desk,
because why would anybody want to talk about
anything else?
Perhaps some foolish reporters would take
video footage of the creature.
Everyone has a phone these days with high-definition
cameras, pictures would be taken and posted.
More and more and more of it would flood the
internet.
Too many simultaneous moles for even the SCP
Foundation to whack.
The news would spread.
Panic and hysteria would spread.
People wouldn’t even know what’s triggering
all this horror if the Foundation didn’t
go public and tell them that it was the pictures
that was killing everyone.
And by then, wouldn’t it already be too
late?
The antidote to fear is knowledge.
It’s why, when anything goes wrong, we’re
refreshing timelines and feeds and news websites
for any kind of information.
And if you were told an unstoppable monster
was killing scores of people and might be
coming to a neighborhood near you sometime
soon, wouldn’t you want a good look at it?
Wouldn’t you want to know your enemy, having
no idea that the mere act of knowing was what
sealed your horrible fate?
By Dr. Dan’s bleak estimations, if only
several million people died as a result of
this kind of scenario, it could be considered
a positive outcome.
He’d seen it all.
But no matter how many times he tried to articulate
this to his superiors, he wasn’t listened
to.
They didn’t take him or the threat that
SCP-096 posed seriously.
Every time he warned of the apocalyptic potential
of SCP-096, he was simply told to get back
to working on those goggles.
It was why he needed to give those naysayers
a demonstration.
It was why a certain photograph needed to
show up in the home of a certain mountaineer.
It’s why all those people had to die.
There was no other way.
The deaths of the civilians and the researchers
and the Mobile Task Force members were, of
course, regrettable, but it was the only way
to prevent the deaths of so many more.
They gave him what he wanted: Permission to
put this gangly time bomb in the ground, even
if the beast’s death was inextricably tied
to his own execution at the hands of the very
employers who authorized him.
The world was full of funny little ironies
like that.
Another one is that, even though Dr. Dan now
had the authorization and funding to terminate
SCP-096, he was discovering that he lacked
another important factor: The capability.
They’d tried incinerating it.
Exposing it to massive amounts of radiation.
Exposing it to an insane degree of kinetic
trauma - the equivalent of being hit by an
out-of-control bullet train.
They’d tested every kind of experimental,
off-the-books weaponry they had access to
through various research projects.
Proton blasts.
Lasers.
High-intensity energy beams.
Nothing.
Even when they fried off every scrap of flesh
on the monster’s body, its unbreakable skeleton
still remained, and in what seemed like no
time at all, it’d be back in action.
Its very existence seemed to mock him.
A guard opened his cell door, staring disdainfully
at the disgraced researcher.
That same guard had slammed his head against
a wall a month earlier.
One of his friends had apparently been killed
in the legendary 096 containment breach that
set this whole sordid thing in motion.
“Up and at ‘em, scumbag,” he said in
a gruff, surly voice, training a handgun on
the Doctor he knew wouldn’t fight back.
“They need you in test chamber six.”
Dr. Dan allowed himself a small grin.
Imperceptible to the guard who clearly hated
his guts.
They’d approved his 096 Vs 682 cross test.
Marvelous.
To all the others, it would seem like just
one more entry in a long line of 682 cross
tests.
He thought it darkly funny - In his eyes,
the Foundation had no hope of ever killing
SCP-682.
Its defining quality was being impossible
to kill, and it didn’t present nearly the
threat to the entire world that 096 posed.
Their futile attempts to murder the lizard
were little more than a money sink to justify
the site’s exorbitant funding.
But perhaps he could turn this to his benefit.
Maybe SCP-682 would hold the secret to actually
killing off his nemesis...
Within 30 hours, Dr. Dan had his disappointing
answer.
Both anomalies had undeniably done a real
number on each other, and Dr. Dan did take
a kind of sick amusement in the mental trauma
that SCP-682 had induced in 096, but ultimately
it was all for nothing.
682 had skinned 096 alive and melted off its
flesh with acid, but once again, that indestructible
skeleton stood firm.
This had been the 27th termination attempt
since the incident.
The 27th failed termination attempt, Dr. Dan
mentally corrected himself.
096’s skeleton kept defeating them - Even
their most ardent attempts to penetrate the
bones and destroy the creature within had
failed.
During a previous attempt, they’d tried
to access the brain by putting a diamond-hard
drill into its eye sockets.
Of course, it was the drill that actually
broke, much to Dr. Dan’s seemingly tireless
frustration.
Needless to say, in the debriefing interview
with Dr. Carver, a researcher who once would
have considered him a colleague, he wasn’t
in high spirits.
If he managed to kill this thing, then he
would always be the hero who made a terrible
sacrifice in order to save many more lives.
If he didn’t kill 096, he was little more
than the monster who murdered all those innocent
people for nothing.
Though you’d never hear him say it out loud.
If it wasn’t for that damnable indestructible
skeleton, this monster would be long dead
already.
If only there was some way to break the creature’s
bones...
That’s when it hit him: SCP-173.
The Sculpture.
A Site-19 icon often overlooked because of
its more “silent but deadly” style, but
undeniably one of the most frightening and
dangerous anomalies out there.
It had racked up a truly shocking body count
since it was first interred at Site-19 in
1993, one broken neck at a time, and it’s
one of the few creatures out there that even
the Hard to Destroy Reptile himself is utterly
terrified of.
Perhaps a monster that practically had a PhD
in breaking bones would be the ideal candidate
to vandalize the Shy Guy’s vertebrae.
Once his proposal was greenlit for initial
testing, Dr. Dan arranged for the Shy Guy
- with a bag over his head, of course - to
be brought into a testing chamber with the
ever-stoic SCP-173.
When all of the researchers and guards were
safely outside, all it took was a single blink
to make all of Dr. Dan’s darkest dreams
come true.
In the nanoseconds his eyes were closed, he
heard the most beautiful sounds in the world:
A loud, fleshy crunch, and a pained howl from
096.
He opened his eyes to an equally wondrous
sight: 096 doubled over at an unnatural angle,
its spine snapped between the fourth and fifth
vertebrae, spinal fluid leaking down the creature’s
flank.
That freaky little sculpture had done it.
It had actually damaged the integrity of the
Shy Guy’s skeleton.
It was at that moment that Dr. Dan knew he
could kill this thing.
Admittedly, there was a containment breach
shortly after that when the bag slipped off
of 096’s head and it charged through the
nearby steel wall, killing multiple people
before being subdued and recontained.
But when it comes to projects involving Dr.
Dan, a mere handful of innocent people being
killed sits comfortably within the acceptable
margin of error.
A day later, Dr. Dan was standing before a
crowded boardroom, with agents, researchers,
and even a few members of the O5 Council in
attendance.
He explained his findings to them, and the
fact that, even more importantly, they may
have a way to bring the wretched existence
of 096 to an absolute halt.
His plans were approved.
Not long after, he was putting them into motion.
Dr. Dan was surrounded by researchers and
heavily armed guards as 173 was escorted into
the test chamber with a forklift. 096 was
there, still bagged.
Off to the side was a giant tub of hydrofluoric
acid connected to a hose and injector attachment.
If this didn’t work, nothing would.
Everyone stood back in a safe zone as 173
was released to do its thing.
Crunch.
Just like the previous time, 096’s spine
had been successfully snapped.
Spinal fluid dribbled down its skin.
Everyone had rushed into the chamber - One
group kept 173 isolated with their stares.
The other, headed by Dr. Dan, prepared the
acid injector and shoved it into the breach
in 096’s spine.
As the acid was pumped by the gallon into
096’s bones, the creature let out the most
horrifying wail.
It kicked and bucked as more acid was pumped
in, melting those indestructible bones from
within.
The creature even began to vomit acid as it
panicked, melting the bag off of its own head.
Some panicked and averted their gaze.
Dr. Dan didn’t.
He stared directly at the creature’s face
for the first time as it melted in front of
him with nothing short of pure elation.
Had he won?
Had he actually won?
The creature let out a gurgling shriek and
the guards opened fire.
Their bullets splattered into the monster’s
melting flesh and bones as it hollered and
shrieked.
They didn’t let up, firing up and down its
body, spraying it with white-hot lead.
It began to melt and bubble away, expanding
into a great, gruesome puddle on the floor
beneath them.
Dr. Dan laughed like a madman.
Even as the guards grabbed him and dragged
him away from the foul-smelling, greasy mess,
bubbling with chemical life, he just kept
laughing.
Even though he knew the death of 096 meant
an equally swift death of his own, it didn’t
matter.
It had all been for something.
The world was saved.
It was over.
He’d finally won.
Now go check out “SCP-096 Shy Guy ESCAPE
- Incident 096-1-A Containment Breach” and
“SCP-096 - Look at a Picture of Shy Guy
in Space?
The Shy Guy Questions and Theories” for
more on SCP-096!